We talked about how
wonderfully quick
it is to use the mobile
devices and that's
one of the things that's
so terrific about it.
But the camera in
most of the devices
are not only low resolution,
which is a problem,
but they're also very
wide angle lenses
so we have a lot of distortion
in most of the images
when we see it in a
particular kind of image
as we're doing here.
When I quickly made this
image in our provost's office,
in fact, I was
very lucky that he
wanted to hang some of the
pictures I made of his work
from years ago in his office.
And I had about 30 seconds to
make the image showing the,
let's call it "art" at
this point, on the walls.
And you see that the
image has problems.
It's distorted, because of
the nature of the camera.
So what I did was I
selected the image
and then I went
to image distort,
where I then tried
to undistort it.
I placed the grid on top to
help me figure out actually
exactly how much
to move the image,
and played around a
little bit, and then I
think I pretty much got it.
I went to the
cropping tool to make
it as symmetrical as possible.
And I think that after these
couple of manipulations,
we can get a more
straightforward image,
just moving your things
around a little bit
and just trying to make it a
truly symmetrical image, which
I think we did here.
And I want you to just take
a look at the first image
that I made and then
compare it to be more
undistorted or fixed image.
And this is what you
can do when you're
looking at mobile
devices that you really
do distort the image,
which is not what we want.